temps avoir révélé son nouveau plan
environnemental aujourd'hui il veut le
gouvernement augmenter ses cibles de
réduction des ges 2030 on évite et
steven guilbeault ministre du patrimoine
canadien et co président du conseil
consultatif fédéral en matière de lutte
contre les changements climatiques
bonsoir steven guilbeault
j'aimerais bien vous parler de culture
ce soir sont une petite minute à la fin
je vous en parlerai où on se fixera un
autre rendez-vous passé quand même votre
principal portefeuille
mais il faudra plus vous attendez un
politique aussi pour défendre des
changements les changements climatiques
alors essentiellement aujourd'hui vous
augmentez vos ambitions vos exploits de
plus grandes ambitions
alors qu'on arrive à peine à rencontrer
celle qu'on s'était fixé tbilissi
blement je fais maintenant comment vous
allez y arriver
d'abord les objectifs que nous nous
sommes fixés à paris ne sont pas pour
2020 mais pour 2030
donc on a encore dix ans pour pour les
atteindre et ce que nous avons fait
depuis 2000 15,6 mis en place plus d'une
trentaine de mesures pour arriver à
atteindre ces objectifs là on peut
parler de choses très concrètes comme
nous demande écrite est une berg des
investissements dans le transport
collectif
on n'a qu'à regarder montréal
prolongement de la ligne bleue des
désinvestissements en transport actif
donc les pistes cyclables
le rm le projet structurel de tramway à
québec et je pourrais continuer comme ça
alors nous avons posé des gestes
concrets qui
et puis c'est vrai qu'au début après 10
ans d'inaction conservatrice à ottawa
c'est sûr que quand on repart tout seul
une certaine lenteur mais on n'a que
nous avons amorcé le virage
et lorsqu'on annonce aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on va là c'est qu'on va aller encore
plus vite dans ce virage là donc plus de
mesures à la fois des mesures
financières donc d un stade c'est
financiers des entreprises
oui exactement des mesures
réglementaires on annonce notamment
qu'on va resserrer des règlements
existants sur la pollution de méthane
qui est un gaz à effet de serre très
puissants normes sur les carburants
propres donc pour que tous les
carburants qu'on utilise au canada que
ce soit dans les transports ou en
industrie et m de moins en moins de
pollution et finalement l'augmentation
de la tarification carbone
oui et justement parce que c'était cela
que le
premier sport il réagissait dans le
court extrait qu'on attendait parce que
pour lui la tarification carmon seules
menaces à l'économie à la compétitivité
on a un tableau on va juste expliquer
rapidement l'augmentation du prix à
chaque année pour arriver en 2030 à 170
dollars la tonne
je pense c'est pierre olivier pineau
récemment qui émettait une analyse mais
je pas le tromper son notion de son
analyse mais c'est pas encore aussi
efficace que ça devait lui que ça
devrait l'être la tarification du
carbone
on n'atteint pas si facilement accès à
nos objectifs non je pense que monsieur
pinault faisait référence à celle qui
existe présentement ou en 2022 on sera
50 dollars la toile vrai et je suis
d'accord avec lui c'est pas suffisant
moi même lorsque j'étais chez khiter
nous avons financé des études et ses
études lorsqu'ils nous disent puis je
pense que le directeur parlementaire du
budget arrive à la même conclusion le il
faut que la tarification carbone soit au
delà de 100 dollars la tonne ce qu'il
serait ce qui sera le cas au canada très
bientôt donc en 2030 nous sont à 170
dollars
alors on nous à vous nous nous en allons
dans cette direction là mais en même
temps est-ce que monsieur ford en partie
raison parce que l'économie et va de
déficit ça va être terrible après la
pandémie l'avoir beaucoup de choses à
rattraper lui la peur qu'après la
pandémie on soit encore pris avec un
obstacle à la compétitivité pas la
rolande économies à cause du prix du
carbone
qu'est-ce que vous visez monsieur ford
et monsieur autour ou et monsieur kenny
en alberta ont tout faux on n'a qu'à
regarder ce qui se passe sur les marchés
présentement les investisseurs
délaissent de plus en plus le pétrole le
gaz naturel et sans et s'en vont vers
les technologies propres vers les
énergies renouvelables
alors bien au contraire s'ils ont vu
compte conserver des emplois de qualité
si on veut conserver une vitalité
économique pour nos communautés pour le
pays
il faut prendre ce virage là parce que
sinon l'économie du 21e du 21e siècle
sera une économie verte où elle ne sera
pas et on peut comprendre on peut
regarder ce qui se passe en allemagne en
corée du sud en france où l'eau si ce
sont des dizaines de milliards de
dollars on n'a qu'à regarder le plan de
lutte aux changements climatiques de de
monsieur byden qui se chiffrent dans les
dents les milliers de
dollars pour voir que tout le monde
prend ce virage là à part quelques
provinces récalcitrantes au canada mais
l'avenir est là et non l'inversé parlant
de monsieur by deux noms vient
d'apprendre qu'on supprime rejette les
recours des lits républicain d'autres
hommes
alors vous allez vraiment des chances de
travailler avec lui vous parler du
pétrole et quand j'étais l'écologiste
militants vous disiez qu'il fallait que
tout ce pétrole là ça reste en dessous
mais là vous êtes propriétaire comme
nous d'ailleurs de craintes pantone
c'est une grosse tache d'huile dans
votre plan j'ai jamais dit qu'il fallait
que tout le pays
ce que ce que j'ai dit ce que c'est que
plusieurs scientifiques avancent c'est
qu'il faut que de plus en plus de ce
pétrole leur reste dans le sol et ici
quand ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est
con qu on offre l'opportunité à
l'ensemble de l'économie canadienne de
prendre le virage conçois qu'on
produisent de l'aluminium qu'on produise
de l'acier qu'on soit dans le gaz qu'on
soit dans le pétrole de prendre ce
virage là et d'ailleurs je constatais
des réactions très positives à la fois
de greenpeace alors là pas à parler les
extrémistes comme comme suit autour et
comme monsieur paul je pense que
l'ensemble à la fois des écologistes des
gens dans le secteur privé d'aidé des
experts des investisseurs tous ces gens
là disent écoutez c'est un plan qui est
un plaqué bain de la lure un heureux
mélange de carottes et de bâtons parce
qu'on peut voir juste avoir des carottes
qu'on peut pas juste avoir des bâtons
mais ma question c'est est franchement
tonnes comment développer de france
mountain sans nuire aux cibles qu'on se
fixe
j'avais raison on en a acheté un
pipeline lorsqu'on regarde les
investissements que nous faisons dans la
lutte aux changements climatiques
versus les investissements pour pour
trois matches en une semaine c'est du du
15-16 pour un le port pour un dollar
dans le pipeline
il y en a qu'un c'est ce dans la lutte
aux changements climatiques alors
qu'hier
il ya un effort herculéen de de la part
du gouvernement pour prendre ce virage
là ça veut pas on va continuer
d'utiliser du pétrole pendant encore on
n'a qu'à regarder le nombre de véhicules
à essence
on commence à prendre on commence à
prendre un virage vers l'électrification
plus de transports en commun plus de
transport actif mais il va rester de
l'utilisation du pétrole pendant encore
un certain temps ce qu'il faut faire
c'est permettre au secteur de prendre le
virage également le formidable émission
scientifique à la radio dans du canada
les années lumières parlait d'une étude
dimanche dernier puis a été repris deux
pense qu'ils parlaient de la qualité de
l'air la pollution de la qui tue
davantage que la pandémie
on a l'impression que c'est facile
d'avoir des fonds pour la pandémie que
pour justement lutter contre la
pollution de l'air est ce que vous j'ai
entendu le l'excellent reportage que
votre compost évidemment ça tue plus
tout est évidemment le problème des
changements climatiques c'est qu'on le
voit pas on va pas là comme vite non
plus mis les impacts sont plus visibles
les diamants que que les changements
climatiques ou si quelque chose de
passablement une matériel et c'est un
plus haut sur le sol le défi
mëme cela étant je pense que on le
constate aujourd'hui la réaction
un des autres est très favorable au plan
fédéral parce que c'est un plan sérieux
nous y avons travaillé pendant des mois
l'équipe de monsieur rock en seine et
lui-même ont fait un travail
extraordinaire auquel j'ai collaboré
également mais donc je pense que c'est
le fruit de tout ce qu'on veut rend
compte qu'on rigole toujours alors
prenons le mot du jour les cévennes où
vois tu impossible comme ministre en
train de mettre en oeuvre plusieurs des
éléments que le premier ministre m'a
demandé en tant que ministre du
patrimoine écouter sur la question des
changements climatiques nous avons fait
campagne en 2019
en dix ans nous nous allons aller plus
nous allons travailler plus fort sur la
question du changement climatique
je pense que la noce d'aujourd'hui
vraiment livre la marchandise
vous avez annoncé l'argent pour l'élève
les plantes et les arbres j'en avais
promis 2 milliards ils sont pas
commencés encore être plantés là mais ça
pourrait me donner du travail à beaucoup
de monde c'est à dire que le fédéral
finance déjà la plantation de deux
millions d'armes par année mais
lorsqu'on annonce et 4 c'est près de 4
milliards de dollars pour en planter 2
milliards d'ici 2030 a effectivement ça
va créer emplois partout qui en fait une
question sur la culture mais on se donne
rendez vous là dessus la pcu à sceaux
hauts-de-seine planche de salut pendant
des mois
mais le nouveau programme est pas tant
que ça les gens qui n'ont pas travaillé
le minimum deux semaines requis à quand
une nouvelle planche de salut en
attendant que toutes les activités
reprennent que les arts vivants
reprennent un mot d'encouragement ou un
espoir là au boulot au nom et écouter le
comité action chômage du québec a parlé
de la pcu comme étant l'équivalent d'un
plan marshall et la nouvelle version est
très semblable à l'ancien
on va continuer de supporter nos
artistes qui ne peuvent pas travailler
au moins jusqu'au milieu de 2010 21 les
critères sont tout à fait semblable les
montants sont tout à fait semblable donc
les prix vraiment on veut permettre
on veut permettre aux gens il y avait
quand même certaines un statique pervers
avec l'appétit du qui faisait en sorte
que les certaines personnes qui
pouvaient travailler ne le faisait pas
or l'on veut encourager les gens qui
peuvent travailler à le faire mais mais
mais supporter sûr j'espère qu'on ne
peuvent pas c'est vraiment c'est
beaucoup le code dans les arts et la
culture
ces villes bourgs merci beaucoup bonne
soirée